l'ordre du jour appelle le vote solennel
sur le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
et réguler l'espace numérique donc nous
en sommes aux explications de vote 5
minutes par groupe le premier groupe à
s'exprimer le groupe écologiste par la
voix de Monsieur Jean-Claude
rau l'effort est
louable merci
beaucoup
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues nous avons accueilli
avec intérêt ce projet de loi dans un
esprit vraiment constructif je crois que
vous l'avez vu tout au long des débats
car nous alertons sur l'importance d'une
régulation de l'espace numérique depuis
longtemps malheureusement ce projet de
loi qui contenait des article prometteur
et sur lesquels nous avons fait beaucoup
de propositions n'est pas allé au bout
de ces amb i Ces ambigués ces impensées
et certaines dispositions sont venu
polluer cette belle idée d'un numérique
régulé mais qui reste un espace de
solidarité et de liberté ce qui est
finalement conforme au projet de société
de la majorité une société managériale
où l'argent prime et où tout le monde
est contrôlé dans le monde physique et
numérique nous sommes certes heureux de
quelques victoires obtenu après de
longues discussions un travail réel pour
identifier l'impact environnemental du
numérique notamment sur l'empreinte
carbone des clouds et des Data Center
les rapports de la Commission européenne
nous alerte en effet sur la hausse de la
consommation énergétique de ces data
centers depuis de près de 40 % depuis
2010 et en tant qu'écologiste nous ne
pouvons qu'être satisfaits que le
gouvernement s'y intéresse enfin nous
pensons aussi qu'il était grand temps
que la France se mette au niveau des
ambitions européennes en reprenant le
digital markets Act le DMA et le digital
services Act le DSA cela va nous
permettre de responsabiliser les gfem et
de passer un système d'obligation de
résultat en terme de modération face à
la puissance des entreprises de cette
taille c'est la seule méthode qui puisse
fonctionner pour nous protéger des
contenus discriminatoires etux et
violence sur Internet enfin la lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement doit toujours
être au cœur de notre combat pour un
espace plus sûr 60 % des jeunes sont
victimes de ce fléau dans notre pays et
nous sommes favorables au mesure de
suspension des réseaux sociaux pour les
personnes qui sont condamnées pour ces
actes il nous semble en effet logique
qu'il faille exclure ceux qui ont commis
ces délits des espaces où ils l'ont
commis mais nous avions déjà pointé des
limites à ce texte que l'on retrouve
encore après cet examen par notre
assemblée aucune ambition pour protéger
nos données personnelles ou pourtant
sanctuariser le droit à communiquer de
manière cryptée c'est pourtant une
demande forte lorsqu'en 2021 la
Commission européenne a tenté de mettre
fin au chiffrement des conversations une
consultation publique avait révélé que
plus de 80 % des citoyens de l'Union
européenne interrogés y étaient
opposés vous nous proposez aussi une
généralisation de l'identité numérique
sur Internet c'est-à-dire un nouveau
degré de concentration de données chez
l'État mais aussi un procédé qui va
accentuer la fracture numérique qui
touche déjà un français sur 6
l'interopérabilité des réseaux sociaux a
aussi été ignoré par ce texte alors que
cela représenterait une avancée majeure
pour favoriser l'avèement de nouveaux
réseaux sociaux et sortir de l'emprise
d'Elon musque et autres Manias de la
Silicon Valley qui tente de plus en plus
de créer des écosystèmes fermés sans
pour autant perdre sa communauté on se
pose aussi beaucoup de questions sur les
techniques déployées pour lutter contre
la pornographie devoir transmettre sa
carte bancaire ou sa carte d'identité à
une autorité administrative pose de
nombreuses questions sur le respect du
droit à la vie privée et semble une
solution vouée à l'échec c'est bien
l'industrie pornographique il faudrait
sanctionner et le contrôle parental et
la prévention qu'il aurait surtout
fallait fallu renforcer et si l'on
pouvait passer outre ces limites ce
texte contient trop de menace pour qu'on
puisse le voter aucune ambition pour
lutter lutter contre les jeunes hommes
et surtout un cadeau
un article surmesure offert à sorar ce
jeu où l'on retrouve des objets qui
valent des dizaines de milliers d'euros
où les gains se base sur les
performances des joueurs de foot le
weekend où il y a autant d'aléatoires
que dans les paris sportifs sur lesquel
il est calqué un cadeau qui leur permet
de dominer le marché en contournant les
règles imposées au jeux d'argent et au
jeux de hasard sur
internet même si les pires ont été
évités des brèches dans l'anonymat sur
Internet ont été créé n'oublions pas
qu'il les pant indispensable pour
garantir notre droit à l'information
qu'il permet aux journalistes et aux
lanceurs d'alerte d'agir et d'enquêter
sereinement sur les abus les plus
dangereux au sommet du pouvoir mais cela
ne semble plus être la boussole de la
majorité la seule ligne qui vaille c'est
celle du tout sécuritaire qui fait très
peu de cas des libertés de nouveaux
amendements sont également venus élargir
la nouvelle peine de bannissement des
réseaux sociaux à des délis d'opinion
révélant la volonté d'un gouvernement de
trouver des moyens de contourner la
censure du web qu'il voulait mettre en
place après les émeutes il ne s'agit
plus alors de réguler l'espace numérique
dont on parle mais de le museler merci
de
conclure je vais conclure rapidement en
en disant que nous partions avec de
bonnes intentions nous avons fait un
travail significatif en commission pour
proposer des amendements qui protègent
nos libertés et s'attaquent au grand mot
du numérique mais sur de nombreux points
le gouvernement a maintenu le cap d'une
société de surveillance et du tout
marché que nous ne pouvons accepter les
écologistes ne pourront donc voter ce
texte et s'abstiendront
je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Soumia
boroa pour le groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues durant l'examen des débats
nous avons exprimé notre soutien à la
volonté de protéger nos concitoyen dans
l'espace numérique pour autant nous
avons pu d'emblé pointer les mauvaises
conditions d'examen de ce texte
rappelons les avertissements du Conseil
d'État soulignant que les circonstances
d'examen je cite ne sont pas de nature à
permettre de garantir pleinement la
sécurité juridique de ce projet de loi
sur le fond la lutte contre l'accès à la
pornographie chez les mineurs est un
combat que nous partageons le non
respect de la loi par cette industrie
marquée par les violences sexuelles n'a
que trop duré rappelons que ce qu'est
l'industrie de la pornographie 90 % des
vidéos pornographiques relèvent du du
code pénal selon la procureur de Paris
viol C l'ultraviolence racisme ce texte
de loi permet des avanés que nous
saluons comme la possibilité de demander
le retrait des vidéos pour les personnes
filmées cependant la prévention est un
contournable et l'un des piliers sont
les cours d'éducation sexuelle et
affective onis par certains de la droite
or actuellement seul 15 % de ces séances
sont sont assurés à l'école et au lycée
moins de 20 % au collège nous devons
multiplier ces séances dont une partie
doiv spécifiquement porter sur la
pornographie et les fausses
représentation qu'elle
diffuse s'agissant de la protection
contre les arnaques de l'outrage et de
la désinformation en ligne nous ne
sommes pas convaincus par la dispositif
proposé sur les filtres anti-arnaque
nous reféutons Laib possibilité pour une
autorité administrative d'imposer le
blocage de l'accès à un service de
communication au public en ligne en
raison des risques importants pour
l'exercice des libertés individuelles
nous considérons que le blocage de site
ne devrait être autorisé que par un juge
judiciaire afin de vérifier que la
demande n'est ni erronée ni abusive au
regard des libertés fondamentales
s'agissant de la peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux nous pointons un
risque de généralisation du contrôle
d'identité en ligne à des atteintes à la
liberté
d'expression alors que nous avions
restreint la liste des délis pour
lesquels une peine complémentaire
peut-être proposée nous déplorons
l'adoption d'amendement de la majorité
étendant le champ d'application de la
peine complémentaire aux provocations
directe et publique à commettre
certaines infractions graves d'atteinte
aux personnes et au bi il s'agit
clairement d'étendre le dispositif à des
événement politiques en écho au propos
du président qui souhaitait limiter
voire de couper la accès aux réseaux
sociaux lors des violences urbaines
cependant nous sommes satisfaits de
l'adoption de notre amendement revenant
sur l'extension de l'amende
forfaitataire délectuelle à certaines
infractions du droit de la presse commis
en ligne s'agissant du cloud nous ne
croyons pas que plus de concurrence ou
plus de transparence suffiront à
favoriser le développement d'un marché
du cloud souverain la stratégie que vous
défendez repose sur la conviction que la
France et les acteurs européens ne sont
et ne seront pas en mesure demain de
rattraper le le retard qui a été
accumulé sur les grands acteurs
américains du secteur en matière de
qualité de service et de sécurité nous
jugeons pour notre part qu'il reste
indispensable sur un sujet aussi grave
que la sécurité des données de nous
donner les moyens de bâtir un Cloud
souverain de favoriser l'émergence
d'acteurs publics qui soit à même de
réguler les stockage l'usage et le
traitement des données d'un côté et de
garantir l'autonomie stratégique dans la
disponibilité du système de l'autre
enfin la la légalisation des jaunou est
l'ouverture d'une boîte de pendeur au
risque multiplle alors que notre pays
compte 1,4 million de joueurs à risque
dont 400 400000 pathologiqu nous allons
autoriser un nouveau type de jeu qui
relève essentiellement de jeux d'argent
et de hasard les risques sont énorme
mais finalement il s'agit de développer
un nouveau marché dans un pays ou il est
déjà saturé de jeux d'argent et de paris
sportif depuis la Libération intervenue
en 2010 ce n'est pas les les enjeux en
termees de santé publique ou de
protection des publics fragiles qui
comptent mais le chiffre d'affaires
généré nous regrettons la méthode nous
nous inscrivons résolument contre ce
régime d'encadrement chers collègues le
fil rouge de mon groupe a été le la
recherche d'un équilibre entre
protection et préservation des principes
fondamentaux comme celui de la vie
privée si nous partageons un certain
nombre de mesures notamment en matière
de pornographie l'équilibre ne nous som
pas ne nous semble pas suffisamment
atteint contournement du juge judiciaire
tentative de revenir sur l'anonymat les
signaux d'Al d'alerte ont été nombreux
aussi le groupe GDR s'abstiendra sur ce
texte je vous remercie je vous remercie
ma cher collègu la parole est à Madame
Estelle yousoufa pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre mers et territoire
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues internet est
un espace ressemblant au Far West la
légende d'une liberté totale une
violence parfois inouï des possibilités
et des richesses vertigineuses l'absence
de lois et des sociétés humaines dont on
peut voir le meilleur comme le pire mais
comme le Far West internet doit se plier
au droit et accepter d'être encadré
parce parce que loin d'être virtuel la
violence et les trafics en ligne ont un
impact sur le réel ils peuvent mettre
des vises en danger affectent le destin
de nos concitoyens légiférer amener de
l'ordre et des règles sur Internet est
une obligation une protection que nous
devons à nos concitoyens l'absence de
gouvernance permet tous les abus et
encourage l'expression de toutes les
violences face aux insultes face aux
escroqueries à répétition face aux
incitations à la haine et au harcelement
nous ne pouvons pas laisser nos
concitoyens sans protection si la
liberté des s'arrête ou commence celle
des autres on connaît bien l'expression
la liberté d'expression d'ailleurs n'est
pas un absolu permettant la création
d'un espace où tous nos droit dont celui
de notre droit à la sûreté est aboli
l'univers l'universalité d'accès la
liberté d'expression le partage des
connaissances sont des valeurs
cardinales d'Internet mais elle
n'autorise pas à toutes les dérives
l'équilibre est précaire c'est le défi
qui qui est posé au législateur mais
notre boussole est là la volonté de
réguler ne doit pas s'apparenter à une
volonté de censurer c'est cet équilibre
fragile que l'Union européenne est
parvenue à préserver avec l'adoption des
règlements sur les marchés et services
numériques et c'est dans cette même voie
que de juste mesure ce projet de loi
s'engage désormais c'était pourtant pas
gagné certains ont voulu ajouter à ce
texte des dispositions de nature àortter
atteinte à cette pondération je pense
par exemple à l'idée émise par le
Président de la République de couper les
réseaux en cas d'émeutes ou de violence
urbaines nous lui préférons la solution
plus consensuelle est finalement retenu
de renforcer la peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux de même nous
estimons que la fin de l'anonymat en
ligne ne pouvait se décréter sur le coin
d'une table l'amendement déposé en cours
de l'examen de texte par le rapporteur
ne nous permettait pas d'avoir le recul
nécessaire sur l'impact d'une telle
disposition c'est une bonne chose qu'il
est finalement été retiré sur d'autres
sujets nous avons pu collectivement
avancer c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
garantir qu'aucun jeune de moins de 18
ans ne soit exposé à des vidéos
pornographiques il n'y a pas de solution
facile ni évidente plusieurs hypothèses
ont été mises sur la table telles
qu'utiliser l'empreinte de la carte
bancaire ou même d'analyser le visage
via une intelligence artificielle pour
estimer l'âge mais finalement une seu
une seule solution nous semble crédible
aujourd'hui celle retenue par le texte
qui consiste à utiliser un tiers de
confiance pour certifier l'âge de
l'internaute souhaitant se rendre sur un
site pornographique en séance publique
certaines dispositions nouvelles ont été
ajoutées pour lutter contre les
violences sexuelles en ligne les
pouvoirs de Pho sont été renforcés cette
police pourra retirer bloquer ou
déréférencer des contenus présentant des
actes de torture de barbarie ou de viol
nous avions défendu un amendement en ce
sens en commission spéciale vous
comprendrez que nous souhaitions le
maintien de cet article adopté contre
l'avis du gouvernement dans le texte
final il en va de même de la création
d'un déliit de sextorsion à l'égard des
personnes faisant l'objet de chantage
aux photos intimes cela répond à un
délit malheureusement de plus en plus
répandu pour répondre aux injures et aux
diffamations mon collègue Christophe
naagelen a défendu la mise en place
d'une amende forfaitaire la majorité de
cette assemblée en a décidé autrement
elle nous prive malheureusement d'un
outil efficace pour lutter contre la
haine en ligne du fait de l'effet de
réseau internet évolue vers une
hypercentralisation au profit de très
gros acteurs privés c'est
particulièrement vrai pour le secteur de
d'Internet en nuage le Cloud l'Europe se
retrouve largement distancée par trois
acteurs américains qui mettent en place
des pratiques
anticoncurrentielles pour surpasser les
petits acteurs voir les étouffer ce
projet de loi va dans le bon sens en
abaissant les barrières à l'entrée et à
la sortie mises en œuvre par ces acteurs
oligopolistiques quelques remarques
additionnelles concernant notre
souveraineté numérique l'article 10 B a
tel que réécrit prévoit que l'État ces
collectivité ses opérateurs veillent à
ce que leurs données sensibles soient
hébergées sur des clouds européens
seulement la nouvelle version propose
une dérogation pour tout projet déjà en
cours ce qui il faut le dire limite
quand même grandement sa portée
s'agissant des objets euh des jeux à
objets numériques monétisables dit
jeunum nous reconnaissons leur
spécificité à m-chemin entre les jeux
vidéos les jeux d'argent et de hasard il
était nécessaire de construire un cadre
juridique qui leur était adapté cela a
été adopté et toujours perfectible
travaillons notamment à la fiscalisation
des jeunumes à quelques exceptions près
donc le groupe liop est favorable à ce
projet de loi qui ins sort une
régulation d'Internet respectueuse des
libertés fondamentales je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma cher collègue la
parole est à Madame la kestur gevenou
pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance bonour madame la
présidente madame présidente monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
chers collègues faire en sorte que
l'environnement numérique ne soit pas
une zone de non droit mais offre les
mêmes garanties de sécurité que l'espace
physique voilà la ligne qui a guidé la
réflexion du groupe renaissance pour
l'examen de ce texte pour se faire et en
nous plaçant entre les deux bornes
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
nousous sommes attachés à traduire dans
la loi les dispositions visant d'abord à
protéger les enfants
la première urgence était de mettre un
terme au scandale que constitue la
surexposition des mineurs au contenu
pornographique en nous dotant dans les
de mois suivant la promulgation de la
loi d'un référentiel auquel devront se
soumettre les plateforme afin de
contrôler réellement l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs les agents de l'arcom
spécialement habilités à sffet et
àermenter pourront directement constater
si les éditeurs pornographiques ont mis
en œuvre un système de vérification de
l'âge conforme au référentiel sur la
base de ces constats l'arcom pourra
prendre des sanctions notamment
financières très lourdes aussi bien
auprès de la plateforme que de
l'hébergeur ainsi que des mesures de
blocage des sites notre groupe est
particulièrement fier d'avoir soutenu
ces dispositifs et regrette qu'il
n'emporte pas l'adhésion de tous les
groupes
d'opposition il est impossible d'voquer
la pornographie sans relever les
représentations dégradantes de la femme
qui ont libre cours marchandisation des
cors asservicement promotion du viol de
la barbarie de l'inceste le groupe
Renaissance affétienne les propositions
de la présidente rioton qui permettent
d'étendre les compétences de Faros pour
retirer à titre conservatoire les
représentations d'actes de barbarie viol
et inceste à obligé les hébergeurs à
retirer les contenus dit de riveng porn
et à faire de la sex torsion une
circonstance aggravante du
chantage le second fléau contre lequel
nous voulons agir et le harcèlement en
ligne nous avons ainsi introduit une
série de dispositifs permettant de
renforcer le pouvoir des juges en
matière de bannissement des réseaux
sociaux nous avons aussi décidé
d'instaurer un mécanisme permettant
d'alerter les détenteurs de l'autorité
parentale en cas de signalement de fait
de cyberhcèlement impliquant un mineur
dans le but de responsabiliser des
parents enfin si nous avons retiré les
amendements visant à se doter de comptes
certifiés nous souhaitons redire ici
notre conviction que l'anonymat est une
liberté qui ne doit pas s'exercer au
détriment de celle des autres protection
et responsabilisation voici les deux
principes qui nous ont guidés pour
l'examen de ce texte ainsi nous avons
souhaité qu'un cadre légal précis soit
défini pour encadrer le secteur
d'activité des jeux numériques
monétisable le groupe Renaissance s
particulièrement engagé pour qu'un
système de vérification d'âge robuste
empêche les mineurs d'accéder au
jeunumes nous avons également souhaité
soumettre ce secteur à des règles pour
lutter contre le blanchiment d'argent la
corruption et le responsabiliser face au
phénomènees d'addiction il nous a
également semblé important de renforcer
pour les élèves les enseignants et les
parents la formation et l'information
quant au mésusages d'une et aux
expositions des écrans ainsi le
dispositif pix sera rendu obligatoire
dès la 6e des formations seront
dispensées et les parents seront
sensibilisés au moins une fois par an au
risques rencontrés sur le web enfin
l'importance de l'utilisation des
réseaux sociaux dans la propagation des
appels à la violence l'été dernier a
conduit un groupe de travail
transpartisan à proposé des des
amendements que nous avons fait nôre
dont l'instauration d'une peine de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux en cas
de provocation directe et publique à
commettre certaines infractions graves
d'atteinte aux personnes et au bien le
projet de loi que nous votons
aujourd'hui pourra aussi s'appuyer sur
les moyens de lutte contre la
cyberciminalité voté dans la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur ainsi que sur
la réserve citoyenne numérique que nous
avons créé par voie
d'amendement enfin je reviens sur les
dispositions de transpos des règlements
européens que contient ce texte issu du
programme ambitieux porté par le
Président de la République lors de la
dernière présidence française de l'Union
européenne elles viennent renforcer
l'indépendance de nos entreprises
nationales et favoriser leur
attractivité ces opportunités économique
offerte par le numérique sont de
véritaable chances pour notre pays et
pour l'Europe en votant ce texte nous
saisissons ces opportunités tout en
faisant en sorte que la tranquillité et
la sécurité se diffuse dans ces nouveaux
ESP je vous remercie merci beaucoup ma
cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien Lopez ligori pour le
rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
quand l'examen du projet de loi is et
réguler l'espace numérique débuté il y a
15 jours notre assemblée faisait face à
un texte clairement honteux honteux sur
le plan des libertés publiques honteux
sur le plan de la défense de notre
souveraineté
numérique par sa mobilisation constante
le groupe rassemblement national a
remporté des victoires décisives sur le
gouvernement et sa minorité
présidentielle nous avons mis en échec
nous vous avons mis en échec lorsque
vous avez souhaité imposer une identité
numérique à tous les Français d'ici 2030
nous vous avons mis en échec en
supprimant l'article 5 bis qui imposait
la création d'un délit d'outrage en
ligne avec une amende forfaitaire
délictuelle sans passage devant un juge
pour des délits d'expression au lieu de
renforcer la justice vous proposez de la
contourner heureusement nous avons mis à
la corbeille cette folie qui piétinait
nos principes juridiques les plus
élémentaires nous avons tenu bon contre
la levée de l'anonymat en ligne que
défendait le rapporteur Paul midi avant
de retirer ses amendements devant le
tapage médiatique occasionné mais nous
n'oublierons pas que derrière lui vous
n'étiez pas moins de 200 députés de la
majorité prêts à le soutenir dans ses
dérives
liberticides nous n'oublierons pas qu'il
y a quelque chose dans votre extrême
centrisme d'intrinsèquement totalitaire
et ce n'est hélas ni la première ni la
dernière fois que vous le
démontrez
dans un même temps quand vous vous
attaquez aux liberté d'expression vous
renonciez à la défense de notre
souveraineté numérique mais c'est sans
compter sur notre résistance face à vos
renoncements grâce à la mobilisation du
rassemblement national et celle du
groupe d'étude souveraineté numérique
que je préside nous vous avons forcé à
réintégrer le 10 ba cet article
permettit de prioriser les entreprises
françaises et européennes de Cloud dans
la commande publique pour les données
sensibles
vouloir que nos données sensibles ne
soient plus entre les mains d'entreprise
soumise à l'extraterritorialité d'un
droit non européen en clair dans les
mains des gars femmes ce n'est que le
strict
minimum de même l'article 10b nous offre
l'espoir que nous éjecterons bientôt du
Elf datata hub le géant américain
Microsoft qui détient les données de
santé des Français depuis bien trop
longtemps
grâce à notre action le pire a été évité
mais vous n'avez pas répondu à certaines
inquiétudes concernant la protection des
données des Français tout d'abord en
refusant de cadrer juridiquement le
référentiel de vérification d'â des
consommateurs de porno vous avez donné
un blancin à l'arcom et vous avez dénié
au parlementaires leur rôle dans
l'élaboration de la loi car oui c'était
à l'assemblée de cadrer ce dispositif et
non à une
administrative ensuite en exigeant des
réseaux sociaux qu'ils empêchent la
création de nouveaux comptes pour les
usager condamné à une peine de
bannissement Vous donnez mandat aux gars
femmes de lever l'anonymat des Français
c'est
inacceptable enfin la première version
du texte issue du Sénat était bien plus
ambitieuse sur la régulation du marché
du cloud et sur la souveraineté
numérique en particulier concernant
exclusion des entreprises
extraeuropéennes de la commande
publique pour
résumer quand l'étude de ce projet de
loi a commencé il était une vraie menace
pour nos libertés publiques et pour
notre souveraineté numérique mais grâce
à la pugacité du groupe rassemblement
national nous avons et les victoires que
nous avons remporté notre ce texte ne
mérite plus notre opposition pure et
simple dans ces conditions le R national
s'abstiendra sur ce texte qui n'est
malheureusement pas à la hauteur des
enjeux et soulève des inquiétudes
légitimes quant à la sécurité des
données nos compatriotes que les
Français soient rassurés qu'ils nous
trouveront toujours soi assurés qu'ils
nous trouveront toujours au rendez-vous
pour défendre leur liberté en ligne et
pour sanctuariser la défense de notre
souveraineté numérique
merci merci
beaucoup la parole est à madameol am
pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues
kelgachi ce projet de loi nous
l'attendions avec impatience il était
censé être une transposition attendue
des règlements européens permettant de
créer un espace numérique plus sûr et
les droits fondamentaux des utilisateurs
seraient
protégés les mineurs les adultes les
personnes vulnérables aux addictions les
personnes qui tombent dans le piège et
les arnaques d'Internet toutes ces
personnes auraient dû être protégé par
le par ce projet de loi mais ce n'est
malheureusement pas le cas nous allons
donc voter contre ce texte et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi tout d'abord
vous avez souhaité protéger les mineurs
en ligne contre qui contre quoi le
gouvernement ne le sait pas et pourtant
il y a un travail immense à faire dans
ce domaine nous avons proposé une
multitude d'amendements sur la
prévention l'éducation sexuelle et la
vie affective à la concernant la
formation et la mobilisation des parents
et des enfants sur le bon usage des
outils numériques mais rien rien n'a
trouvé grâce à vos yeux vous êtes resté
buté sur la problématique d'accès à la
pornographie qui semble être le Bou
émissare et le seul danger d'Internet
pour les mineurs
même si les dangers sur internet
existent vraiment le système de
vérification d'âge que vous allez mettre
en place est un colosse au pied d'argile
une façade bien pensante qui cache au
monde qui cache un monde de données
interchangeable partageable et
piratable depuis des années nos
établissements de santé nos
collectivités territoriales et nos
grandes entreprise subissent des
attaques de très grande ampleur il y a
un peu plus d'un mois c'était Pôle
emploi qui s'est fait pirater les
données de 100 millions
d'allocataires et malgré tous ces
risques vous persistez dans la
numérisation des données sensibles en
rajoutant à l'état l'objectif de créer
pour 2030 les identités numériques de
tous les Français et toutes les
Françaises sans prévoir d'abord leur
sécurisation ainsi sous le prétexte de
vouloir protéger les mineurs et
l'ensemble des citoyens des dérives et
des violences certaines qui existent sur
Internet vous installez petit à petit
tous les outils pratiques d'un contrôle
social de
masse facilement détournable ce ne sera
pas la première fois qu'une solution
technologique serait dévoyé de son
utilisation principale les dérives et le
scandale des Predator files devrai nous
alerter face à tous les dangers et les
violences que nous pouvons rencontrer
sur Internet la protection des citoyens
mérite une justice à la hauteur des
enjeux sous prétexte d'une réponse
inefficace des institutions judiciaires
face aux procédures de blocage de site
internet vous la dépouillez tout
simplement de ses compétences en donnant
les pouvoirs à
l'arcom mais si la justice est
inefficace pourquoi ne pas lui donner
les moyens nécessaires vous en avez le
pouvoir mais vous ne faites rien pour
l'améliorer pour une réponse adaptée il
faut des budgets adaptés et les
personnels en
conséquence comme si le transfert de
compétences du pouvoir judiciaire vers
les administrations ne suffisait pas
vous rajoutez des peines complémentaires
liberticide comme le bannissement des
réseaux sociaux ou le filtre
anti-arnaque totalement contraire aux
libertés
d'Internet et dans ce mélo législatif
vous avez curieusement ajouté à ce
projet le fameux le fameux article
sorar justement critiqué par plusieurs
groupes parlementaires sur ces
bancs cet article vient légaliser les
jeux à objets numériques monétisable
dont le Conseil d'État avait noté la
particulière dangerosité pour les
mineurs et le risque de blanch
argent mais si de nombreux gardesfous
ont été rajoutés il n'y avait aucune
urgence légiférer sur les jeunumes dans
ce projet de loi au contraire la loi
existe déjà car il s'agit d'un jeu de
hasard et
d'argent cet article permettra de créer
de nouvelles addictions et au jeu et
faire perdre de l'argent à ceux qui en
ont le moins voilà comment vous protégez
les citoyennes et les
citoyens pour finir concernant
souveraineté des données sensibles nous
avons évolué dans le bon sens imposant
désormais aux administrations et aux
opérateurs de l'état de respecter le
référentiel secnum cloud mais les termes
mais en terme de souveraineté nous
aurions dû aller plus loin avec une
territorialité du traitement des données
il est également urgent de considérer la
question de l'impact environnemental des
clouds et de notre développement
numérique alors croyez bien monsieur le
ministre que nous resterons à l'affu des
négociations européennes au cours des
mois à
venir comme vous l'aurez tous compris ce
projet de loi n'est en définitive qu'un
enchevêtrement liberticide et
déshumanisé de mesures cavalièr isolé
dépourvu d'un objectif clair et défini
la protection des citoyens et des
mineurs n'aura jamais été votre boussole
mais uniquement un prétexte à
l'établissement de votre politique
sécuritaire merci beaucoup la
parole c'est à Monsieur Victor
aberdassau pour les
[Applaudissements]
républicains merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente monsieurs
les rapporteurs ch monsieur le ministre
chers collègues ce texte monsieur mon le
ministre déjà passé devant le Sénat
reflète la détermination du Parlement à
doter la France d'une législation à la
hauteur des défis actuel ce présent
projet de loi tente par conséquent de
répondre aux exigences européennes
formulées par deux règlements européens
le digital service Act et le digital
market Act ce projet représente une
avancée en combattant les dérives de
l'industrie pornographique et en
protégeant davantage nos mineurs il
établit en outre un cadre expérimental
de 3 ans pour les jeux numériques
monétisables offrant dorénavant une
protection pour la jeunesse nous aurions
toutefois souhaité que nos propositions
pour restreindre le champ d'application
soit davantage retenu pour éviter les
éventuels effets de bord qui pourraient
survenir sur le Cloud la dernière
version de l'article 10 B a reflète bien
une vision commune et une volonté
collective de parvenir à héberger les
données sensibles des Français dans un
espace souverain sans aboutir à des
contraintes opérationnelles
insurmontables de plus l'introduction
d'un un critère spécifique relatif au
contrôle des participations financières
étrangères constitue un gage de
confiance supplémentaire apporté par les
républicains les députés les
républicains ont également fortement
contribué à renforcer le périmètre de
contrôle de l'Autorité nationale des
jeux en lui ouvrant la possibilité de
tenir compte des technologies utilisées
par les jeux à objets monétisablebles
pour un meilleur contrôle du respect de
leur obligations légales et
réglementaires c'est un apport important
même s'il doit impérativement
s'accompagner gag de moyens
supplémentaires pour faire face à ces
nouvelles responsabilités la peine
complémentaire à l'article 5 sans
également aller dans le bon sens de la
lutte contre la haine en ligne véritable
fléau de nos plateformes de réseaux
sociaux ou trop souvent nos valeurs
démocratiques sont sacrifiés sur l'utel
de l'anonymat et de l'impunité toutefois
nous avons le devoir monsieur le
ministre de vous exprimer nos
appréhension sur un certain nombre de
mesures présentes dans ce texte tout
d'abord sur le renforcement de
l'interdiction de la la pornographie sur
les mineurs nous appelons à la plus
grande vigilance face au référentiel de
l'ARCEP dont le format nous a été
partiellement révélé et dont les
modalités d'application restent encore
assez vagu le référentiel mis en place
devrait également répondre à une
protection des données renforcées
notamment concernant le tiers de
confiance car nous ne parlons plus ici
de données personnelles mais bien de
données intimement personnelles je
dirait même de donné intime de plus le
contournement potentiel de ces nouvelles
obligations au moyen de VPN doit nous
conduire à la plus grande humilité face
aux avancées concrètes de ces mesures
qui nécessiteront des compte-rendus
réguliers quant à leur efficacité sur
les genumes l'interdiction claire faite
aux mineurs représente un progrès mais
le chemin à parcourir pour lutter
efficacement contre l'addiction est
encore long en ce sens nous resterons
d'une vigilance absolue quant au risque
d'addiction que ces jeux peuvent
entraîner chez un public très jeune tout
juste sorti de l'adolescence je pense
NOTAM notamment au 1825 ans le rapport
d'étape en ce sens sera examiné avec la
plus grande attention pour protéger nos
jeunes face à ces risques grandissant le
sujet d'anonymat en ligne devra
continuer d'être exploré égard aux excès
dont nous sommes trop souvent les
témoins impuissants l'identité numérique
pourra s'avérer un jour utile mais que
si elle aboutit à la plus grande
simplification des démarches
administratives car il faut le rappeler
mes chers collègues l'éleectronisme
reste très présent sur notre territoire
et à l'ône des avan technologique c'est
une donnée collective qu'il ne faut pas
négliger les nombreux débats que nous
avons eu d'ailleurs dans cette hic cycle
avec les parlementaires de tout bord sur
la liberté d'expression l'anonymat le
stockage des données l'identité
numérique et la sobriété numérique
témoigne des enjeux habissau et des
réflexions que nous devons continuer à
mener sur des sur ces thèmes essentiels
certes nous gardons nos inquiétudes sur
l' l'applicabilité de certaines mesures
comprises dans cette loi certes nous
aurions aimé que la sobriété numérique
soit davantage abordé certes nous
aurions aimé que les jeunumes soient
davantage encadré mais cette loi
constitue dans sa globalité une avancée
pour la protection des mineurs et pour
notre souveraineté au regard de
l'évolution
fulgurante du numérique nos débats
doivent être récurrents nos réflexions
constantes et nous devons pas nous
arrêter à ce projet de loi alors
monsieur le ministre au terme d'un
suspense intenable les républicains
voteront en faveur de ce
texte merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur erouan
balanan pour le groupe
démocrate madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés couvrez ce sein que je ne
saurais voir par de pareils objets les
âmes sont blessées si dans cette célèbre
pièce de tartuf Molière se moque des et
de le de leur hypocrisie nous pourrions
la reprendre à notre compte s'agissant
de l'impérieuse nécessité de protéger
nos enfants dans l'espace numérique face
au contenu illicite ou inadopté à leur
jeune âge et à leur fragilité mais nous
pourrions aussi parler de l'hypocrisie
de nos oppositions de l'extrême gauche
qui ont refusé tous les dispositifs de
protection dans ce texte préférant faire
confiance à la main invisible du
numérique le groupe démocrate ne peut
donc que saluer monsieur le ministre
l'aboutissement de ce texte issu d'un
d'un travail parlementaire il s'agit
d'un texte indispensable au regard du
travail précédemment réalisé à l'échelle
européenne mais c'est avant tout un
texte essentiel essentiel face aux
dérives rencontrées en ligne et au
monopole exercés par certaines
entreprises nous avons ainsi fait le
choix dans ce texte de transposer au
plus vite le Data la data Act dans ce
marché dominé par les acteurs américains
nous adoptons des règles essentielles
qui permettront de casser les monopoles
incompréhensibles nos débats auront
ainsi permis d'avancer sur la nécessité
de la protection de nos données
sensibles telles que les données de
santé je sais Monsieur le Ministre que
les décrets que vous serez amenés à
prendre sont très attendus nous nous
apprêtons aussi à voter une loi qui
répond aux enjeux de protection des
internautes à commencé comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure par nos enfants pour nous
pour eux il est urgent d'assaignir
l'espace public numérique et lors de nos
travaux préparatoires sur ce projet de
loi je ne vous cache pas mon étonnement
face au sentiment de satisfaction
exprimé par certains acteurs du
numérique en les écoutant nous aurions
pu croire ou nous pourrions croire que
l'espace numérique actuel est sain et
sécurisé presque un espace où il fait
bon vivre et bon bien converser alors
s'il ne faut pas nier les efforts qui
ont été faits par la majorité de ces
acteurs ils ne peuvent se contstanter
pas plus que nous de ces petites
avancées tous doiv tous pardon doivent
comprendre les responsabilités qui sont
les les leurs dans cet écosystème et la
nécessité pour eux de maîtriser les
risques qui
afférant lors du travail en commission
puis en séance nous avons eu à cœur de
doter l'état d'outils pertinents et
efficaces non seulement pour punir mais
aussi pour que chacun en bonne
intelligence puisse utiliser ce
formidable outil d'émancipation
d'information et d'innovation qui est le
numérique et à ce stade de mon
intervention je remercie les rapporteurs
pour leur travail ainsi que toute
l'équipe des
administrateurs collectivement nous
avons travaillé pour trouver des
compromis sans lesésiner sur un principe
celui de la responsabilité j'aime
rappeler un concept que nous devrions
décliner dans le numérique c'est le le
le concept du pollueur payeur dans cette
logique force de constater que certains
acteurs ne jouent pas encore pleinement
leur rôle et peut-être qu'il faudrait
qu'il mettent un peu la main à la poche
pour assaainir l'espace qu'il qu'il
pollue mais pour cela nous devons
définir des interdits clairs et précis
la délectualisation de l'outrage sexis
et sexuel lorsqu'il est commis en ligne
en est un c'est une avancée le recours à
l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle
permettra alors de réprimer plus
efficassement et plus rapidement ses ses
outrages dans l'espace public numérique
et le groupe démocrate se réjouit à ce
titre que nous nous soyons gardés de
créer un délit risquant d'englober des
des infractions plus sévèrement réprimé
et pour lequel il est nécessaire de
laisser le temps à la justice et la
décision du
juge nous devons aussi prévoir des
sanction à la hauteur de l'interdit et
la peine complémentaire d'interdiction
et de suspension d'accès au comptes
ayant été utilisé pour commettre les
infractions est une véritable avancée et
je tiens à vous remercier Madame la
rapporteur Louise Morel pour le travail
transpartisan que vous avez conduit à ce
sujet sur l'anonymat versus l'impunité
nous avons eu des débats euh je crois
que nous nous avons été avec France
numérique à un stade satisfaisant euh il
ne faut pas confondre anonymat et
impunité et dans ce texte nous avons
lutté contre l'impunité en
ligne enfin je tiens à saluer le travail
de notre assemblée sur les jaunumes je
rappelle que sur les jaunumes il
n'existe aujourd'hui à ce stade aucune
législation donc tout ce que nous avons
fait est du mieux et tout ce que nous
avons fait est plus protecteur que ce
qui ce qui existait aujourd'hui non non
c'est pas faux madame madame Chikirou et
comme d'habitude ah c'est pas vous pour
une fois c'est pas vous je suis désolé
pour une fois c'est pas Madame Chikirou
s'il vous plaît cette expérimentation
car il s'agit d'une expérimentation nous
permettra de suivre le développement de
ces jeux et d'adapter si nécessaire leur
réglementation et nous ne pouvions pas
rester sans réglementation sur le sujet
en tout état de cause le groupe
démocrate votera ce texte indispensable
pour sécuriser et réguler notre espace
numérique et assurer la souveraineté de
la France en la matière je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue je vous
indique que je fais annoncer le scrutin
dans l'ensemble de l'Assemblée national
il nous reste deux orateurs la parole
est à Monsieur Hervé Solignac pour le
groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente Monsieur
le le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique vaste
ambition
indissociable d'autres régulations celle
des rapports sociaux trop souvent
dégradés celle du libéralisme effrainé
sur lesquels prospèrent les mercenaires
de la toile et autres criminels des
plateformes car en effet chacun le sait
cette toile est à l'image du monde les
tensions qui la secou les usages qui en
sont faits et qui menacent les plus
vulnérables tout comme notre économie
parfois ne sont que les symptômes d'une
société qui va mal et pour Sécur C
espace rien ne sera plus efficace que
l'éducation la culture des politiques de
justice d'apaisement social tout ce qui
nous permettra de prévenir et de traiter
la cause plutôt que la
conséquence ce texte aurait-il vu le
jour sans le travail de l'Union
européenne je ne le crois pas et je
voudrais saluer l'Europe qui dans ce
domaineil vous plî un peu de silence
salueer l'Europe qui dans ce domaine
nous ouvre la voie par ses règlements
elle est la seule grande démocratie au
monde qui n'attend pas que les
plateformes se régulent d'elle-même
alors dans ce texte il y a des avancées
gageons que les publics les plus jeunes
n'accéderont plus aussi facilement à des
contenu pornographique que le
cyberhcèlement sera mieux sanctionné que
les autorités administratives
indépendantes seront plus efficac dans
le contrôle des plateformes sur tous ces
sujets nous avons veillé à ce que soit
préserver l'équilibre de ce texte un
texte qui doit combattre les activités
illégales sans restreindre les libertés
qui doit favoriser la réactivité des
autorités indépendantes sans jamais
écarter le juge en dernier ressort enfin
ce texte s'attaque aux pratiques
anticoncurrentielles des grandes
plateformes notamment dans le secteur du
cloud là aussi le crédit en revient à
l'Union européenne en marche de ces
avancé il y a bien entendu des regrets
l'article 15 sur les jeunumes gâche
quelque peu l'économie générale de ce
texte monsieur le ministre nous avions
là l'occasion de traiter des jeux
illégaux et de la sensibilisation aux
pratiques addictives vous avez fait le
choix assumer jusque dans les propos de
certains députés de prétexter un soutien
à l'innovation française quoi qu'il en
coûte notamment pour la santé des plus
jeunes le développement fulgurant ou le
caractère précurseur de C start-up
françaises dont sorar bien entendu
semble vous aveugler vous avez passé
par-dessus bord l'objectif de protection
des mineur
sorar détient un record parmi d'autres
une valorisation à 5 milliards d'euros
pour quelques dizaines d'emplois créés
ce record est triste on peut bâtir des
empires ultracapitalistiques qui ne
servent que des intérêts particuliers
conserver un cadre juridique flou mais
bien utile
cibler un public vulnérable et recevoir
la reconnaissance du
gouvernement regret également sur la
méthode employée en confiant à l'arcom
le soin d'établir un référentiel avant
même que son contenu de se dessine sur
ce point comprenez que le législateur se
sente un peu désaisi et que l'on puisse
s'interroger sur l'efficience de ce
référentiel
français l'essentiel a cependant été
préservé pour nous et je voudrais saluer
votre volonté de dialogue monsieur le
ministre ainsi que votre attachement à
un certain équilibre à cet égard nous
avions tracé une ligne rouge s'agissant
de l'amendement de notre collègue
rapporteur général son amendement a été
retiré et c'est une bonne chose vous
avez su entendre notre exigence d'une
obligation de résultat pour éviter que
les plateformes ne se
réfugient derrière la seule mise en
œuvre du référentiel de même que vous
avez accédé à notre souhait de contrôler
les contenus pornographiques qui mettent
en scène des actes de torture de
barbarie de viol ou d'inceste enfin je
me satisfait que nous ayons pu
introduire quelques gardesfous au
jaunumes sur la restriction de leur
accès au majeur ou bien encore sur
l'interdiction des mécanismes de prêt
pour l'acquisition de NFT ainsi ce texte
vient poser une brique supplémentaire
dans le long travail d'édification d'un
cadre nécessaire à la régulation du
numérique il nen demeure pas moins que
depuis 20 ans le droit du numérique
évolue au gré des réglementations
européennes et se construit en quelque
sorte par sédimentation sans réelle
approche globale ni prospective le temps
de cette approche globale devra
s'imposer un jour peut-être pour
codifier l'espace numérique en tout cas
pour éviter la superposition de textes
trop nombreux et aux dispositions
parfois inopérantes en l'état et parce
que cette brique supplémentaire
constitue une protection même imparfaite
sur des sujets parfois graves nous
voterons en faveur de ce projet de loi
je vous remercie mon cher collègue alors
nous avons encore un orateur je vous
demande vraiment d'essayer de garder le
calme et le silence pour qu'elle puisse
s'exprimer dans des conditions correctes
madame agè Carel pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur général Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs thématiques
mes chers collègues YouTube Twitter
TikTok ma autant de plateformes que le
commissaire européen Thierry Breton a
interpellé ces derniers jours afin de
les enjoindre à respecter leurs
obligations de modération institué par
le digital service Act dans ces temps
perturbés Internet et en particulier les
réseaux sociaux sont détourné de leur
fonction initiale et deviennent des
armes des armes de cyberacellement des
armes de propagation de faussse
information le temps est maintenant venu
d'armer les les États européens pour
sécuriser cette espace pour protéger nos
concitoyens dans l'espace virtuel comme
dans la vie
réelle l'Union européenne a joué
pleinement son rôle créer un socle
commun de normes protectrices dans cet
espace sans frontières l'action du
législateur français seul placerait la
France dans une situation isolée voire
impuissante s'il en fallait une de plus
l'action conjointe des États-membres en
matière est une preuve qu'au-delà du
symbole d'unité des peuples l'Union
européenne sait se donner les moyen de
sa souveraineté et de sa
compétitivité dans ce nouveau champ de
liberté la loi doit protéger en
particulier les plus vulnérables et je
crois que ce texte atteint les objectifs
qu'il s'est fixés sécurisés et régulés
soyons collectivement fier des solutions
pertinentes et équilibrées que ce texte
contient c'est aussi le fruit du travail
remarquable par le rapporteur général
Paul midi et chacun des rapporteurs
thématiques je tiens à saluer en
particulier mes collègues du groupe
horizon apparenté et apparenté le
président de la commission spéciale Luc
lamirot et Madame Anne leenanf dont la
quasi-ttalité des articles ont été
adopté à
l'unanimité le groupe horizon et
apparenté a pris pleinement la mesure de
cette nécessité de construire un ordre
public
numérique après la loi studire imposant
l'installation par défaut d'un contrôle
parental la loi marcangéie vient
conditionner l'inscription d'un mineur
de moins de 15 ans à un raison social à
l'accord d'un de ses parents n'oublions
pas que l'efficacité de toutes ces
dispositions tatos tient aussi et
surtout en un mot l'éducation celle
peut-être des députés aussi peut-être
l'éducation à respecter l'oratrice
merci nous ne sécuriserons véritablement
l'espace numérique que si chacun d'entre
nous est véritablement formé aux non
s'il vous pla mes chers collègues 2
minutes 30 de silence s'il vous plaît
pour écouter notre oratrice s'il vous
plaît allez-y forme aux opportunités et
au risqu que ce nouvel espace virtuel
présente il faut aller plus loin et je
crois qu'au-delà de la norme il faut
changer de braquet et former massivement
nos jeunes nos enseignants et les
parents nous nous réjouissons de
l'adoption d'un certain nombre
d'amendements de notre groupe sur le
sujet oui nous sommes convaincus qu'il
faut protéger nos jeunes pour qu'ils
vivent en ligne comme dans la la vraie
vie des chose de leur âge les jeux
d'argent sont interdit pour les mineurs
dans la vraie vie ils doivent l'être
aussi en ligne je crois à ce titre que
la rédaction des articles 15 et 15 bis a
trouvé cet équilibre intelligent et nous
saluons l'adoption des amendements que
nous avons porté avec les autres groupes
de la majorité qui permettront de
véritablement vérifier l'âge des
utilisateurs les plateformes ont une
responsabilité et c'est sur elle que
doit reposer cette obligation de
vérification effective de l'âge or
certains s'exonèrent de cette
responsabilité au moyen d'arguments
fallacieux c'est le cas de certains
sites pornographiques je le rappelle on
parle ici de responsabilité pénale ce
texte permettra ainsi utilement de
s'assurer du respect de leurs
obligations en plus d'une obligation de
résultat les éditeurs de sites
pornographiques devront se conforter à
une obligation de moyen la mise en place
du référenciel pensée par l'arcom
respectueux de la vie privée et des
données personnelles c'est une avancée
majeure
lorsque l'on sait que les effets
délétaires que peuvent avoir une
exposition précoce à des images
pornographiques ce projet de loi
comporte en outre un arsenal important
de protection que nous avons soutenu
tout au long de l'examen de ce texte
protéger nos concitoyens contre les
actes malveillants qu'il s'agisse de
cyberhcèlement ou d'arnaque en ligne
mais aussi protéger nos entreprises et
nos collectivités en posant les bases
d'une souveraineté
économique et numérique au sein de
l'Union européenne enfin si ce projet de
loi était l'occasion de souligner le
nouveau champ de risque et de danger que
le numérique a ouvert n'oublons pas de
le rappeler l'immense opportunité qu'il
constitue une opportunité de
simplification notamment des rapports
laborieux avec l'administration nous
saluons l'adoption de l'amendement que
nous proposions visant à expérimenter
une plateforme unique rassemblant
l'ensemble des services publics impôts
démarges d'Assurance Maladie allocation
familiale procuration de vote inscrp à
la crèche par exemple autant de
démarches qui sont aujourd'hui
effectuées au sein de différents sites
au sein de différents organismes qui
communique parfois mal entre eux nous
sommes convaincus que le numérique
constitue à ce titre une chance inouï
qu'il faut nous saisir dont il faut nous
saisir vous l'aurez compris le groupe
Horizon est apparenté profondément
convaincu de la nécessité de se de
construire ce nouvel ordre public
numérique votera en faveur de ce projet
de loi merci merci beaucoup chers
[Musique]
collègues je vais vous laisser
tranquillement regagner votre
place
voilà qui est fait je vais donc mettre
au voie le projet de loi le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
561 exprimé 437 majorité 219 pour 360
contre 77 l'assemblée
adop je CIS que monsieur le rapporteur
général vous souhatiez dire un mot
oui merci madame la Présidente écoutez
je voulais remercier l'ensemble des
collègues et en particulier tous les
collègues qui ont été très investi sur
ce projet de loi merci pour votre vote
je crois qu'on a eu des débats de grande
qualité à la fois en commission et dans
l'émicycle ça fait plus d'un mois un
mois et demi qu'on est sur ce texte et
c'est une très bonne chose merci merci
évidemment à Monsieur le Ministre merci
au président de la commission spéciale
merci aux collègues rapporteurs pareil
pour leur engagement sans faille dans
ces derniers mois et je pense qu'on peut
être collectivement très fier que ce
texte a été adopté il nous permettra
d'améliorer la sécurité sur l'espace
numérique de lutter contre le
cyberharcèlement qui gangraine nos
réseaux sociaux et qui gangrain l'espace
numérique il nous permettra de lutter
contre les arnaques en ligne merci cher
collègue contre les arnaques en ligne
grâce au filtres anti-arnaque et contre
l'exposition de nos enfants à la
pornographie et il nous permettra aussi
de réguler un nombre d'activités dans
l'espace numérique très utile à réguler
voilà merci infiniment et très bonne
journée à tous merci beaucoup donc je
suspends la séance quelques instants et
nous reprenons immédiatement sur
l'examen du projet de loi de finances la
séance est suspendue